jetzt habe ich gerade auch ein bisschen
mit gehört es kam gerade eine
Katastrophenmeldung rein und zwar wurde
die Hohenzollernbrücke gesperrt wegen
eines Pudels da frage ich mich muss man
die Brücke sperren wegen eines Pudels es
ist ein Pudel es ist ein Pudel genau
unten Pudel
das möchte ich nicht kommentieren
wichtigste Frage vorweg was ist jetzt
mit dem Pudel also die Strecke ist
wieder freigegeben worden ob der Puder
aufgegriffen wurde das weiß ich leider
nicht ja ja aber er ist zumindest nicht
mehr zu sehen und dass das sieht man
jetzt hier auch zur tatsächlich erst
Meldung xxx meldet ein Hund Klammer auf
Pudel Klammer zu und was bedeutet jetzt
zum Beispiel diese Zahl 9 das sind die
zusatzverspätung das bedeutet wir haben
jetzt 996 Minuten Verspätung wegen des
Pudels das ist richtig genau der hat das
eingebrochen auf 47 Züge verteilt